okay so we're gonna fill in more of this
as you can see but for now I want to hit
pause on this diagram and I want to kind
of like formalize or systematize the
process I introduced to you on Tuesday
about how do we determine which one of
these kinds of stationary points it is
so that's where I'd like you to now have
a look at the piece of paper you picked
up on your way in today which looks like
this I know it looks complicated okay
but I promise wants to become more
familiar with it you'll be looking at
the thing you are this is not that big a
deal I'm just trying to represent it
visually for you that's the first thing
I'll say the second thing I want to say
is it's actually gonna get more
complicated in future lessons there's
actually you might notice a big gaping
hole on the bottom right hand corner of
this this diagram that's because later
on next week probably we can fill it so
anyway one step at a time he's really
going to begin I hope you noticed that
the this gigantic flowchart is split
into two sections two sections there's
an above and below this fat dotted line
okay those two sections correspond to
those two questions that we asked about
stationary points that I introduced on
Tuesday
what's the first thing we ask about
stationary points we ask where are they
right where are they it's the first
basic thing right so the word we used
with that start of an L is located right
so the top half is just about locating
those stationary points so that's what
that part of the flowchart is and then
down below if you find to the station of
words what's the thing that you do with
them yeah you're gonna try and work out
what which one is it like there's so
many different kinds right so we say
what what kind are they and that the
language we use is we determine the
nature right so determining the nature
of these stationary points is the second
half of this okay all right so let's
have a look at where we begin right at
the top we start with y they will hand
you if they're looking for station first
they'll hand you the actual function so
you begin with the original function
now as we go through this one I'm
actually to do is actually work through
an example with you so here's an example
I'd like us to actually work with y
equals x squared minus 4x plus 3 it's a
very simple looking graph it just has a
few features that are relevant to us as
you'll see so this is going to be the
example that we've worked through as we
step through the chart ok now if you
know that you're looking for stationary
points the first thing that you have to
do is you've got to what's the process
we're gonna start with we're gonna
differentiate thank you so that's the
first step right you differentiate and
what that's going to give you of course
is the derivative and this is its own
sort of like ah here's the first thing
that I do so let's go ahead and work out
that what's the derivative of this
particular function is if I've defined
the function is y I'm gonna go do int X
and I think I already had it it was 2x
minus 4 fantastic I hope that's become
it's an easy looking function so this
becomes reflexive so there's the
derivative right and then I wonder if
you recall the next thing that you do
with that derivative you're looking for
stationary points you're going to solve
when is that derivative equal to zero
fantastic so you're going to solve dy on
DX equals zero okay well we will do that
in a second by the way but before we do
there's one of two things that happens
after this occurs right you will solve
it and in most situations you're going
to find there are some stationary points
right you will find that there there is
a place or places where the derivative
is equal to zero but it's just important
I'm gonna ask you for some examples of
this in a second it's just important to
recognize sometimes you try to do this
you try to solve when's the derivative
equals zero and you can't do it there's
no solution that arrives Syrian wife yes
and in filler
all right yes for you just to clarify
okay um now I said I was going to do
this
can someone give me an example of a
function and you know a bunch of these
that you're not going to be able to find
a solution to this say again 1 over X
what does whatever X looks like that's
the UM that's a hyperbola right it never
comes to a place where it stops and it
gets really close to that at the
asymptotes but if you try and solve for
du and DX equals zero you won't find a
solution give me another one
a semicircle hmm now I'm gonna say it
depends on what kind of semicircle it is
and I'm gonna park that thought we'll
come back to it later think think of
even simpler functions guys look at all
of them we spent two weeks a straight
line if if it's not horizontal right any
other straight line will never have a
stationary point okay how about how
about you know think carefully we're in
sort of like 219 situation what kind of
functions are really important to us
right now
exponential functions do not turn right
logarithmic functions
do not turn this no stationary point of
any kind okay so therefore we conclude
off of that is if there's no solution to
do in the next equals zero then there
are no stationary points simple okay so
when we go through this process you
don't always get an answer out of it and
that tells you some information okay all
right
let's go ahead and do this let's let's
go ahead and solve so here's my
derivative dy/dx equals zero so 2x minus
4 equals 0 right so you guys can
probably because it's a simple equation
tell me what the solution is right it's
x equals 3 very good so I've got x
equals 2 I found a solution and what
that tells me is for a stationary points
exist and I will put points I'll put the
s in a in a pair of brackets because I'm
there maybe as we've just determined
they may just be one but we at least
know there are some to work with ok now
we're still the top half of this we're
still trying to locate right so I want
you to help me remember and the error
here helps you out right what's the
final step in locating a stationary
point because that arrow going back up
is meant to tell you something
have a think why is that arrow heading
back up to the original function why
would I go back to that it's here to get
your boat you know you're just randomly
chelina yeah okay fantastic
I'm gonna take this x value and I'm
going to substitute it back into the
original function because and we should
write that by the way I'm going to
substitute X values back into the
original function of course I'll only
substitute one x value if I've only got
one and why am i doing that it's because
if I've got an X to find where that
stationary point is I also need a Y so
let's go ahead and do that now
if x equals 2 then Y is equal to and I
hid the whole function back there so
let's have a go here you've got 2
squared minus 4 lots or 2 plus 3 okay so
4 take away 8 is negative 4 so then you
add 3 which gives you negative 1 so I've
got an x value I've got a Y value so
therefore I can say the coordinates 2
comma negative 1 that's my stationary
point so at this point I'm half done I
guess I've located this stationary point
and so far that's that's all I needed
ok I've got my coordinates as my example
but as we've already pointed out this is
not usually where you stop normally we
want to find out a bit more so I'm going
to transition pass on to the second half
I'm going to determine the nature okay
that's right
good question so what I would say right
here like I'll write on the left hand
side where my conclusion is at the
moment all I know is that this is a
stationary point because I don't know
what kind of stationary point it is
that's all I can say right I could say
that y equals x squared minus I could
say it is stationary at this point all
these things are equivalent okay but
it's worth noting I don't usually
conclude this point I usually go to the
second half okay